recently I was looking at a list
detailing the most visited websites in
the US at the top you had your common
culprits Google YouTube Reddit Amazon
Facebook duck Dogo wait a minute duck
Dogo is the sixth most visited website
within the US pulling in 2.3 billion
visits every single month what the hell
that means that duck Dogo is almost
twice as popular as Bing an official
search engine from Microsoft who chat
GPT as a partner this also means that
duck ducko is more popular than
Instagram Twitter Netflix Uber Airbnb
Spotify and basically any other surface
that I didn't name at the beginning if
you're like me this is a shocker I mean
I've heard about Duck Duck Go here and
there in passing as some sort of private
alternative to Google search but I've
never actually seen a single person
actually use Duck Duck Go also if I'm
being honest most of the so-called
alternatives never really make it that
far due to just how powerful big Tech is
things like signal and be real usually
just have 5 Seconds Of Fame before
Fading Into Oblivion never to be heard
of again but that doesn't seem to be the
case with Duck Duck Go in fact duck the
go boasts a user base of 80 million
people and that was as of 2020 that
number is slly closer to 100 million
today obviously these numbers are
nothing in direct comparison to Google
but in comparison to everything else
it's insane but not only has Duck Duck
Go grown to insane Heights but they've
also stood the test of time Duck Duck Go
launched on February 29th 2008 meaning
that they've been going for nearly 16
years at this point or about the same
time as Bing but unlike Bing Duck Duck
Go didn't have the full power and might
of Microsoft behind them they started
off as just a no-name player and have
quietly risen to be one of the most
popular websites not just in the US but
around the world where they rank as the
10th most visited website so here's the
insane story of Duck Duck Go and how
they were able to single-handedly break
into the Cutthroat search engine market
and take on some of the biggest
companies in the
world taking a look back the story of
Duck Duck Go takes us back to the
Village of Valley Forge Pennsylvania to
a man named Gabriel Weinberg over the
years Gabriel has kept a pretty low
profile which is not that surprising
given the type of business that he runs
there's almost nothing about his
childhood online other than the fact
that he was born on New Year's Day of
1979 and that he attended Local Schools
what we can assume though is that
Gabriel was extremely sharp as he would
end up attending MIT on two separate
occasions once for his Bachelor where he
majored in physics and once for his
Masters where he majored in technology
policy he didn't just jump straight into
Duck Duck Go after college though in
fact Gabriel ran multiple Ventures
before duck tucko the first of these was
an educational product called learn
action the goal of learn action was to
increase parental involvement in primary
schools and though that was a noble
cause it didn't really go anywhere he
would end up spending 2 and 1/2 years on
it before trying to sell it to a
nonprofit and after those talks fell
through he would just go on to work at
the nonprofit instead to save up some
money using this cash he would go on to
create another startup called the names
database in 2003 a rather unoriginal
name but it did have a rather novel
concept it was basically a social media
site that made it easy to find people
that you went to high school and college
with in order to search on the website
you could either pay a membership fee or
refer someone else to the website which
is quite a clever growth strategy within
just a few years names datab base would
grow to 20 million fre users and 50,000
paying users but despite the success of
names database Gabriel was self
admittedly not all that interested in
the product itself so he would end up
selling when a good offer came around
from their biggest competitor
classmates.com for an estimated $10
million in cash in March of 2006 after
all having $10 million by the time
you're 30 means that you could just
invest the money well and end up as a
billionaire by the time you die but
Gabriel didn't sell names out of Base to
take things easy he sold it so that he
could spend all his effort on something
that he truly believed in and could work
on for decades the only issue though is
that he didn't exactly know what that
was so he would just spend his time
working on a bunch of side projects that
he found interesting one of these side
projects was a Google search results
Optimizer the tool would try to filter
out spam and content farms and
prioritize results from websites with
direct answers to the search Gabriel
would further build upon this idea over
the course of a year until he ended up
with his own search engine that he would
dub duckduckgo.com if you've ever
wondered what that means well then I'm
sorry to say that there is no real
meaning to the name it was just
something that popped into Gabriel said
one day when he was thinking about the
children's game duck duck goose and he
ran with it clearly Gabriel isn't all
that into naming and branding but he did
choose a rather auspicious day to launch
duck tucko February 29th 2008 and with
that Gabriel had officially began the
uphill journey of taking on
Google
shortly after launch duck dug go did
receive some notable press coverage for
example they would be featured on Tech
crunches elevator pitch Friday in
December of 2008 they would also end up
as a finalist on the boss Mashable
challenge but while this press coverage
definitely didn't hurt the key to duck
duck ghost growth strategy has always
just been Word of Mouth people tell
their friends about this private
alternative to Google they give it a
shot they like it and then they tell
more people about it hearing this you're
probably wondering what's so special
about Duck Duck Go in the first place
well obviously it offers privacy but it
goes much deeper than just that and it's
completely different to something like
incognito on Chrome all Incognito does
is locally delete your search history
after you close the browser Incognito
doesn't do anything to stop websites or
Google from tracking your history in
fact Google will usually be helping
these websites continue to track you if
you didn't know Google is by far the
most popular choice for companies to
track website activity you know what's
the click-through rate how long is the
average session what time of day are
people visiting How likely are they to
convert and so much more in fact 75% of
the top 1 million websites in the world
use Google trackers to optimize their
business and Facebook trackers are
present on 25% of the top websites as a
website owner these analytics are a
godsend but as a user they're not all
that great the good news is that duck
ducko actively tries to block as many of
these trackers as possible so using duck
ducko not only gives you more privacy
when searching but it makes you more
invisible across the web in general also
this has the added benefit of making
websites a lot faster as these trackers
won't be bogging down their performance
putting privacy and performance aside
though the benefit that intrigues me the
most is actually search quality now this
might be a bit confusing to hear how
could a small startup possibly have
better search quality than Google well
for one duck Doo isn't as incentivized
as Google to push their own ads meaning
that you'll see less ads but more
importantly Dro doesn't try to Pander to
your thoughts and beliefs you see
Google's main goal isn't to deliver you
the best and most accurate search
results possible it's actually in their
best interest to show you the search
results that best align with what you
already think this way you're pleased
with what you see and are more likely to
continue your Googling session on a
broad scale this means that if you lean
left you're likely to be fed CNN and NBC
news articles and if you lean right
you're likely to be fed Fox and daily
wire news articles but this works on a
much more micro scale as well if you
think that luids are way better than
Teslas then you're likely to find
reviews that praise Lucid even if that's
the minority of reviews Duck Duck Go on
the other hand it doesn't know anything
about you meaning that they couldn't
curate results based on your interests
even if they wanted to so duck Dogo
basically offers a more private internet
experience with less ads better
performance and no bias no wonder so
many people who are in the know have
opted for Duck Duck Go but despite
everything that's going for Duck Duck Go
taking on Google is obviously still no
easy task which brings us into the
Growing Pains of Duck Duck
Go one of the the first struggles that
Duck Duck Go ran into was funding for
obvious reasons self-funding a popular
search platform is rather expensive
especially when you're collecting no
data and showing fewer ads for example
even with 1.5 million searches per day
duck do go was only pulling in
$115,000 per year which was probably not
enough to even pay just their modest
three employees fortunately though in
late 2011 Union Square Ventures would
agreed to back duck duck go with $3 to5
million which has gone a long way in
helping them scale but just as they
finish addressing their funding issue
they would run into another issue Google
you see it just so happened that Google
owned the domain duck.com Google wasn't
even trying to spite duck ducko they had
just bought up a bunch of domains with
simple words early on in case they ever
wanted to use them and doc.com just
happened to be one of them once they
realized this though they would would
turn around and use it despite duck
ducko they would basically just make
duck.com redirect to Google search
honestly from an outside perspective
this was quite a funny troll move but
I'm sure that it felt a lot different
from duck duck Go's perspective not only
were they not able to lock in duck.com
but duck.com was actively directing
potential users to Google fortunately
Google would eventually come around
whether this was truly out of Goodwill
or just a way to avoid antitrust
litigation Google would hand over the
domain to duck ducko in 2018 allowing
them to largely clear up the confusion
but even now duck Doo is still not truly
independent from Big Tech ironically
their biggest challenge now is not
Google but actually Microsoft you see
duck Duo doesn't actually run any of
their own searches they're more like a
middleware whenever you search they go
ahead and mask your identity and run the
search through Bing from there they'll
filter the results returned by Bing
remove trackers and targeted ads and
show you the remaining results for
obvious reasons Microsoft isn't exactly
the biggest fan of this solution leading
to a constant back and forth battle
between duck ducko and Microsoft
regarding unmasking and REM masking
users despite all these challenges
though duck ducko has managed to come
out on top in terms of popularity though
it is unlikely that there'll ever truly
be a financial hit just due to how the
business is structured while they are
profitable they only pull in $100
million in annual revenue despite
controlling 2.5% of the search Market in
other words even if they controlled 100%
of the US search Market they'd only be
pulling in $4 billion if we throw in the
rest of the globe it might push that up
to $10 billion but that's still nothing
compared to Google 58% of Google's
revenue still comes from search ads
which adds up to 162 billion every
single year so Duck Duck Go won't be
living up to that anytime soon but that
was never their goal anyway their goal
was to just create a modest profitable
private alternative to Google and that's
exactly what they've done to great
success would you consider using duck
ducko over Google comment that down
below another Community oriented
business that's killing it is Craigslist
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Harry and I'll see you
guys on the next
[Music]
one